un presidente de Colombia de vuelta a
Venezuela Gustavo Petro se reunió con su
homólogo Nicolás Maduro en el Palacio de
Miraflores sin grandes anuncios pero
Aparentemente más cerca del regreso de
Venezuela a las instituciones regionales
sobre los pasos en función de una
reconcidación del sistema interamericano
de derechos humanos han sido muy
receptivo
y así será en el transcurso de las
próximas semanas en relaciones este
interesante tema planteado por el
presidente Gustavo Petro los jefes de
estado hablaron entre otros asuntos de
una mayor colaboración migratoria de
liderar la preservación de la selva del
Amazonas y de la necesidad de fortalecer
el intercambio comercial Petro acusa a
las mafias de controlar la frontera
vamos a reconstruir incluso las
relaciones que había a nivel de
inteligencia
para poder golpear ya no tanto al obrero
del narcotráfico que por ahí anda sino a
los dueños del capital que son los que
casi nunca se han golpeado Colombia y
Venezuela reabrieron su frontera de
2.200 kilómetros en septiembre después
de tener el paso restringido desde 2015
y bloqueado por completo desde 2019
también hacía años que no se veían un
presidente colombiano y su homólogo
venezolano la última vez fue en 2016 en
un encuentro entre Nicolás maduro y Juan
Manuel Santos en la frontera venezolana
Gustavo petroso posesionó el 7 de agosto
y ese mismo mes anunció la restauración
de relaciones diplomáticas con Venezuela
una nueva era después de que durante el
gobierno de Iván Duque Colombia fuese
uno de los 60 países que reconocieron a
Juan guaidó como la autoridad en
Venezuela
[Aplausos]